the protests that have consumed Hong
Kong for more than three months started
because of a proposed bill that would
have made it easier for mainland China
to extradite citizens from this
semi-autonomous city violent clashes
between protesters and police culminated
in a confrontation at a subway station
on August 31st when police appeared to
beat demonstrators with batons possibly
resulting in one fatality though
authorities dispute that plane the
activists politicians and academics we
spoke with said that the protest
movement has become about much more than
the extradition bill which the
government has since withdrawn it's a
fight for the survival of an island of
liberalism in the shadow of an
increasingly authoritarian super state
with ambitions of global dominance we
are at the front line between the grade
2 dictatorship among human history which
is ccp and the freedom world and Hong
Kong which shows that we stand with the
freedom world and of course we hope the
wrath of the freedom world can support
us in his battle in this war between
dictatorship and free Hong Kong's
peculiar one country two systems'
governance model began when Britain
handed over its former colony to China
in 1997 on the condition that it be
allowed to maintain its existing
governance structure for another
half-century this city of more than 7
million prospered economically with
China mostly holding up its end of the
bargain Hong Kong's Constitution
protects freedom of speech and assembly
but the city enjoys what's been
described as Liberty without democracy
the government including the city's
chief executive isn't entirely elected
by the people if you did this interview
with me in 1997 and asked me when do you
expect that people in Hong Kong would
get this universal suffrage I think most
people at the time would say well maybe
ten years that was almost like part of
the promise in the basic law but as time
goes by you know promises were broken
though he supports the universal
suffrage Charles Mok wasn't elected by
popular vote to his position in Hong
Kong's legislature but rather selected
by a smaller pool of stakeholders as an
official representative of the city's
tech sector like Mok the majority of
Representatives didn't get there via the
ballot box and not surprisingly most
members of the legislature who were not
voted in by the citizens side with
mainland China and not the protesters as
one journalist put it Hong Kong is
controlled by a conspiracy of local
tycoons and mainland communists
colluding against the citizenry so the
citizenry has turned to the streets
largely because we are not a democracy
because the government is not you acted
I think it straight level protests
largely peaceful are actually important
means for the Hong Kong people to
protest government actions and protest
has often worked the 2014 umbrella
movement led the government to withdraw
a proposal to pre-select
a limited slate of presidential
candidates and the recent uprising led
to the withdrawal of the extradition
bill the 2014 protests also spawned a
mostly youth-led movement to increase
democracy as a way of preserving the
city's autonomy
Joshua Wong was just 15 when he led a
successful movement overturning a plan
to impose a pro Communist Party history
curriculum in Hong Kong schools he then
started the political organization Demma
Sisto which has played a central role in
the protest movement and even elected a
candidate to office who along with other
youth activists elected in 2016 were
later disqualified from serving at their
swearing-in ceremony last month
Sixtus Leung and Yayoi Ching unfurled
banners calling for an independent Hong
Kong - people who support dependents
logically we cannot find a way out one
of the more controversial youth leaders
is six despacio Leung who is part of a
right-leaning movement advocating for
full independence from mainland China
I don't think Hong Kong can was survived
if people among the world don't trust
our system they don't trust they would
be safe when they travelled your Hong
Kong or doing business in Hong Kong why
they will come and why they need us so
to keep separation from China keep
distance from China to try to be a more
natural state is the best solution but
the problem of course is that there
seems to be no institutional channel by
which you can do this and also I don't
see and it really tangible movements to
actually make that into a reality so a
lot of that is just talk Long's
pro-independence position is still
considered radical in Hong Kong and
experts point out that Chinese state
controlled media often highlights
independence activists in an attempt to
portray the protests as part of a
radical separatist movement in need of
violent suppression they're using this
solo propaganda to cater to the domestic
audience to justify for the kind of
force they use on Hong Kong do you think
that strategy might backfire on China
it is backfiring more and more people in
Hong Kong particularly opposed to young
people are beginning to say that I'm
only a Hong Kong it's all because of
this action reaction the more you push
more I want to break away if Hong Kong
remained under the ruling of CCP we can
never achieve him like the universal
suffrage like separation of power like
freedom of speech like all kind of
freedom zhang gongjin fashion a decision
to nurse around Andorian
to michigan yoshi-yan was sought out to
to do kind show though we see 97% off
the entertainment scene silencing
themselves and we just trying to keep
out of trouble pop singer Denise Ho is
one of the few local celebrities who is
publicly supporting the protesters
others like Jackie Chan and Liu Yifei
the star of Disney's live-action Mulan
reboot have praised the Hong Kong police
and criticized the demonstrators for
being too destructive right now we are
at a point where the communist
government they do not accept this
stance of neutrality for them saying
silent means that you are with the
protesters they are trying to force
everyone to choose aside most of the
people they would be afraid to go
against this huge machine because
everyone wanted wants a piece of the
Chinese market who has been banned from
performing in the mainland
she says her records have also been
removed from Chinese stores and some of
her international shows have been
cancelled because of alleged security
concerns mainland China detained
employees of a Hong Kong bookstore known
for selling literature critical of the
Communist Party on dubious charges
prospective candidates with certain
controversial views are barred from
running for office leaders of the
protests have been imprisoned and
there's talk of making it illegal for
Hong Kong residents to boo the Chinese
national anthems such as that this
recent soccer match
the core values that we are safeguarding
our freedom to speak our minds to take
our political stance to protest without
fear of being prosecuted that has been
something that has been given to us in
the earlier days as a British colony a
lot of Hong Kong people think that like
15 years ago we had a higher level of
freedom or freedom of speech in or in in
various aspects but now it seems that we
can feel a Hong Kong becoming more and
more like China in terms of political
values I I always believe that one of
the biggest capture in Hong Kong and the
Beijing government the emphasis on rough
law freedom freedom speech human rights
and also maybe to a lesser extent
democracy activists see the fight for
more democracy as a path to securing
more Liberty they're demanding the
citizens be allowed to fully elect the
city's legislative body and chief
executive but winning that right
requires approval from Beijing
it's really not only about Hong Kong and
Hong Kong government or the communist
government behind it it's really a fight
of these universal values that we as a
more hybrid city might be aligned with a
lot of different Western societies and
then the set of covenants values that
the Chinese government and maybe even
other author Terran governments around
the world they are trying to bring into
the world with their powers personally I
feel this is a very global fight of
these two different sets of values the
activists are also appealing for help
from the US Denise Howe Joshua Wong
Demasi Stowe and some other
pro-democracy activists appeared before
a u.s. congressional committee on
September 17th and urged US lawmakers to
pass the Hong Kong human rights and
democracy Act which would make the
city's bilateral trade and travel
agreements with America contingent on
China maintaining Hong Kong's autonomy
it would also levy sanctions against
Chinese individuals accused of violating
the rights of Hong Kong citizens and
would instruct immigration officials not
the punished visa applicants who've been
arrested for participating in the
protests with America already in a trade
war with China such a move could
escalate tensions but advocates say it
would be easy for China to comply Hong
Kong issue is quite different from the
trade war Hong Kong issues is actually
preventable after the u.s. passed the
law is up to China to design they can
just doing what they did in the past
they do not have a tighten control on
Hong Kong at the moment I have to say
that I'm pretty pessimistic because it's
just so difficult to stop China from
extending the kind of power and control
that they wish for particularly with the
current leader of the country region
pain it seemed to be a very much of a
total control type of mentality type of
person in a way I think many of us are
probably even thinking that what we're
trying to do right now is to slow down
the change in the wrong direction
preserving whatever we got throw one
country to system at the moment
despite that pessimism the movements
leaders say they have no choice but to
keep fighting for liberty and democracy
or else Hong Kong will be subsumed into
an authoritarian state there's only wing
or nothing if we lose we lose a
generation ok this generation they will
be put in the jail they will be
harassing so or nothing and now whenever
there is a Cantonese saying that this is
the end game of the Hong Kong people
they if they do not take to the street
they will have no future for the next
generation